goo
nan じぇい
今日は外れ雪はです深夜の廃校のれ仮設に
泊まったら何か起きる雪
[音楽]
はいコーナーが歌えば自国が夜の2時なん
ですけども私今2年前ぐらいに廃校になっ
た古い学校に切っておりますこちらご覧
ください
理科室です皆さん私思いました
今まで様々な強いはそう言ってきたと思う
んですけれども一番怖い場所
深夜の理科室施設ないかなと思って音楽別
にですね廃校になった理科室で一晩泊まっ
てみようと思います
[音楽]
掃除機っていうかマジで怖いです
パー
誰かと来ればいいんですけど結局こういう
ってな一人でないとね怖いことが起きない
のでもう8 boys 一人で来てるわけ
なんですけどもとリズムで理科室の中入っ
てみたいと思います
では行こう
アルミ軽い軽い
me
[音楽]
スズムになってないしずるしなってるよ
ああ
次つきましたいっ
もう
ref
too
言えばわかりますよね鈴虫なってない埋め
教えるよね静かにちょっと
あ
を音ズレます yeah
いやな文化というわけで打つ鹿馬むしっ
てけど物理が室に入りましたーーー
なるほどなあこれはまずいね2年前に廃校
になったということで全然まだ
明るいですね比較的
塗り耳普通に家だふわぁめっちゃレカスっ
ぽいなぁこういうの何を買ってたんでしょ
うわ懐かしい交換地を行く頻度がネベン
やつケイトがめちゃくちゃさなんか記録2
エバーまあアルコールランプアルコール
ランプこういうのもまだ残ってるねー
最悪いやー高はとりあえずカーテン手を
染めていきますね1回
者が白い勝手にしようと思ったすけど黒い
ほうがかっこいいので黒にしました
[音楽]
寝ることがない1人で理科室にはきたもの
のブックここで一晩泊まる予定でしてただ
パッと見て何かベッドみたいなものって
いうか寝る場所がないので廃校ということ
でちょっと保健室から
ベッドとっていきたいとおもいます
[音楽]
バッハねえてる汚そう絶対嬉しいただき
たらどうしましょうね
ば
5個しかないからね違いの学校でこんな
ことすると怒られると思った廃坑という
ことで許してくださいのか今日ここで寝
ます
ん
par
ああああああ
ん
バッハ
24時になりましたとりあえず暑いですね
それ以外お得に何ら変化ない感情します
ん
全体むっ体にレイバンのサングラスつけて
あげました田口ても全然健全ですし
ちょっと熱すぎて寝れがどうかがまずで
不安なんですけれどもまぁちょっとそこが
頑張ってみようと思います
汗が止まらない時の80時になったので
せっかく学校にいるということで
深夜徘徊してみましょうなかなか深夜の
廃校に1人でいることないですからね愛校
心や胚芽してこいと思います
24ズーム学校が一番怖いですから
[音楽]
の
うん
どこがどこだかよく分かってないんですよ
止まりでしょうね
時といる
アーニャせますだからもう死んだと思い
ますよあーすいません集めたんやたりし
ます
頑張ります
ですと深夜徘徊していますだけどしに配管
していきましょう
ここが2回いるー
[音楽]
まじの教室じゃんなんか廃校といっても
撮影とかではたまに使われているみたいで
つってもで結局本当に学校として使われた
わけだから生徒の気持ちとか感情とか先生
の思いとかいろいろあったんじゃない
でしょうか
コンピューター室だコンピュータ室ですね
授業2にコンピューターを使う授業は
いかに戦線に貼りないようにエロサイトを
見るかが鍵になりました
ここにもう1いたら俺普通に心臓ともず
汚れいうね打つ映り込んだですよねですね
音楽室弾
は床が高い高床式倉庫すねこれあーまじ
やばいまじ声マジこえーマジ強い音が下
スマじゃない word 対抗だ太鼓
すごいを正しいのかな
[音楽]
かピアノだパナマから
ならないでくれよ
[音楽]
ん
ua うーん2
me
なんだこれ本やフォント素質なんかな
わーと素質っぽいですね僕人生で本読み
切ったことだけデルトラクエストの一環
くらいですねたら読み切ったことあるのか
とは無理ですね
カブトした上階レストランシリーズが好き
でしたうわぁ家庭科室が不安は済むん
まあ
調理師手大嫌いでしたねまぁコップが俺
白い
なあ撮リカスっぽいなぁ
これねワンとかで食器が多いんですね
[音楽]
ん
ます鍵かかってやっぱでも老化が一番多い
んですよねー猫0
あれなんですよね事故物件言っとるで
止まりだったから怖いもの知らずやつって
どこでも依存性も3階いきますあ
ないというか牧場7分
いいえ
はいど移動します
屋上だ屋上ですこれちょっと暗くてわかり
づらいですよね1多くゾーンに来ましたお
得に何まねーなー戻ります
会合くノ一大歓迎にいさんがいらっしゃる
ので誰もいないわけではないのでそこを
ちょっと安心です
保菌室は保健室も多いんだよなぁ
ございまします
あーはっはっは
メリメリ一体目たメインは理科室だから
そんな俺深追いしたくないよすぎはザ体育
館行けますか
絶対体育館が絶体育館の入り口だこれウは
後ろ声誰もいないよね体育館行きます
王様は4 c ろ
[音楽]
くらって感じもありません何か良いサイズ
の小学校ですね
[音楽]
を望んでおります
理科室に戻りぞ俺の夜はここからだ
仕事します
r
ああああああ
サーバー
day
[音楽]
だった
ブーッ
はいえーもうすぐ3時ですね丑三つ時で
ちょっとね扇風機も切って寝ようかなと
思ってて風があるとさ音も聞こえずらいし
風で動いたみたいになっちゃいそうなんで
もう風が戦闘機ないときに動いたらもう
それもすなるということですよねもう次で
海パン履いて寝ます
杭を集めたのでコレなにかあったら
そういうことですじゃあおやすみなさい
しま
ていそう
ませ
んぬわああ
を
[音楽]
gooこう来てね欲しいレンズあっきくる
かなぁ
聞こえます
こっちは
なってないけど
こっち目
ただですなら塩すごいですよもう普通に曲
聴いてるだけなのに
こっちね
うわぁ凄い凄いつまんないけど片方だけ
すごい砂嵐音がなっている
松屋地味なさいああ
ああああああ
人かと思ったら全然をやったあ分過ぎた
通った
う
を
ああああああ
おってー
4号
ああああああ
を
goo
おおーー
r
[音楽]
音
を大
を
おっ
[音楽]
を
he
[音楽]
mele
then